what the government can't tolerate is
basically having large denomination
notes on steroids it can't allow people
to make large transactions easily across
borders I think we need to worry about
the privacy of those of us who use
hundred-dollar bills in Bitcoin it's not
right to assume that we're all criminals
and therefore need to have these things
taken away from us what the Federal
Reserve and other central banks do is
reverse money laundering money
laundering takes dirty money and makes
it clean
they take clean money and it ends up
being dirty
so when banking services are shut off
for people who are doing legal and
harmless business cash is a badge of
freedom
welcome to this fourth debate of the
third season of the Seoul forum at the
subculture theater in downtown Manhattan
I'm Jean Epstein director of the so
forum tonight's resolution reads
governments of the advanced industrial
economies should phase out the use of
paper money in the form of large
denomination notes and sharply restrict
the use of crypto currencies at every
cell form we try to have a warm-up act
whenever we can get Dave Smith to come
at this stage Dave Smith as many of you
know is the guy who runs the part of the
problem podcast I've been ordered to be
on it twice it so don't miss podcast and
without further ado I bring you Dave
Smith to warm us out big round of
applause for Jean Epstein who puts
together this amazing this amazing
series always a lot of fun tonight's
gonna be a great event thanks to reason
thanks for that copy that's unbelievable
really cool picture of George HW Bush on
the cover I uh
too soon all right cool whatever
starting an illegal war it's okay all
right what are you guys a bunch of
socialists I thought we're gonna have
fun up here on this well sorry give me a
break I think I think there's an off
chance that my wife might be going into
labor right now but I'm not leaving cuz
it's just this is come on it's debate
about cash and she didn't understand
either but it's sometimes I just wish I
was a dad in like the 50s because then
if you're if your wife was going into
labor you could just be like all right
call me like when the kids ate or
something and like I'll show up with
like a baseball mitt or whatever I don't
know I don't really understand how the
50s worked but from what I understand it
was a lot easier than today I don't know
it's not easy being married to a
pregnant woman much easier than being a
pregnant woman but still not
that he is a hormones go nuts I was I
was tossing in bed the other night
because I couldn't sleep and my wife
goes uh what are you doing you can't
sleep that's okay I'm just not tired
she was will go in the living room hang
out watch TV for a little bit and I was
like okay cool and I went out in the
living room and then she came out ten
minutes later and she just goes what are
you doing and I was like remember we had
the whole thing with the service I get
to bed and I was like what's going on am
i a prisoner in here like it's like are
you just [ __ ] with me like was this I
think she snapped is what I'm trying to
say I don't know but I might be leaving
halfway through this one anyway the
debate it's a little bit above my
paygrade
I'm not really smart enough to
understand that should we abolish cash
and Bitcoin I don't know so basically
you're telling me I just can't do drugs
anymore I think is this is that am i
understanding this correctly
how would drugs work at this point you
basically have to prostitute yourself
for weed at that point if it's I can't
give you cash or Bitcoin I'm in a lot of
trouble be a lot of drug dealers with
just like extra pairs of shoes and stuff
but I don't know maybe it's a good idea
I I can't tell I don't understand any of
this though I don't understand how
banking works I think it was I know it's
some type of Jewish plot but I don't
know exactly like I just don't know the
details exactly of how high people took
over that world I don't even understand
why I have a bank account to be
completely honest I don't get any of it
like I think banks started because
people had gold and they had to lug
around gold and then they were like can
I store my gold at your place and they
were like we'll give you a piece of
paper to let you know you got gold at
the bank but then we got rid of gold and
we just had paper and they started
giving us checks and they were like if
you keep your paper here we'll give you
other paper that represents the paper
you have here and we were like cool that
sounds like that's worth a 12 buff
service fee a month or what like I don't
even know why I have and now I don't
even use checks anymore I'd pay
everything with like stupid websites
like PayPal and and venmo and I still
have my paper at this Bank
I don't even know what I don't even have
that much money why am i keeping this at
a bank I asked the banker once at Chase
that's where I am not trying to brag but
I'm at i bank with Chase little
mom-and-pop shop down the street and
they're very aggressive by the way I
don't know have you been to a chase
recently like they come right up to you
at the door like you come into the bank
and they're like hi sir what brings you
into the bank today and you're like back
off bro like I don't banking I don't
know what did you think I didn't come to
check on you like I'm making a deposit
and then I'll be on my way
and then they bring you to their desk
and they try to basically just sell you
things but like it's it's ridiculous
there's nothing to sell me like you know
there'll be like oh we just want to take
a quick second and make sure you know
all your account information is correct
and you're utilizing all of the best
strategies for your money and I'm like
really my account the one with negative
$200 at it like what strategy do you
want to use here's my strategy I was
going to deposit 200 bucks and bring
that son of a [ __ ] up to a nice solid
zero like what do you does that seem
like a good strategy to you like I don't
get a night so I asked this guy at one
point I was like why do we even have
bank accounts is what I asked my banker
and you would think if you worked at a
bank you would have like a really quick
answer prepared for that well obviously
this is why you need a bank account but
I just asked him I was like why do we
have a bank account and he goes what do
you mean I was like you're a banker what
do you mean what do I meet like why why
do i why do all of us have bank accounts
and he was like what you got a bank
account I was like that's not a very
good answer to my question like why why
do we have a bank account and why does
everyone like why don't I just have like
a prepaid card with no bank involved and
I just pay my bills with the card and
put money on the cart like why are you
even here and he was like well I mean
this is just how we do it
and I was like I don't understand any
more but I think you should be fired
immediately right there's you should
have a better answer than that prepared
but I was like why don't I just take my
money out and keep it at home and that
he finally came up with an answer and it
was not a good
but he goes you can't keep it at home
cuz what if your house burns down and I
was like alright first of all are we
living in like bamboo houses in the 1600
like is this a common problem outside of
California like our people's houses
really just burning down like from what
Al Gore tells me my issue is my house is
gonna be underwater not burning down so
I don't I'm not concerned with this but
Americans we're all broke you ever see
those studies words like like something
like half of Americans can't scrounge
six hundred dollars together in the
event of an emergency but we're all
still putting our money in banks because
we're afraid our house is gonna burn
down like we were to you like oh my god
what would happen if my house burns down
what would I do with my three hundred
and twelve dollars I better I better get
this to an official building with fire
resistant walls correctly anyway I don't
understand it I'm sure there's a better
reason than that I don't get it I don't
know from what you know I get all of my
hard financial news from Donald Trump
because that's where I go you know this
is a reliable source and according to
him China is the ones who's like they're
their currency manipulating a bunch
those are the banks you really got to
worry about the Chinese Americans were
all on the up-and-up over here like the
Federal Reserve open books they do what
they tell ya no this is what I've been
led to believe I think it's amazing of
all of trumps think like of all the
populace Bannen thing the fact that
they've gotten people angry at China I
think is the greatest accomplishment
they ever pulled off but they're like
China's ripping us off and you know you
just like met with the leader and he's
like well we'll think about you know
making a deal with them but they've been
doing a lot of shady stuff like China we
have the best deal ever with China our
deal with China is that China makes all
of our stuff and then we consume it but
first they lend us the money so we can
buy the stuff from that that's our deal
with China which is like look we used to
make stuff we don't make it anymore but
if you make the stuff for us we will
consume it but we didn't mention this
we're broke
so we're gonna need some money but if
you lend us some money
we'll use that money to buy the stuff
that you slaved away making and then we
will enjoy it you're welcome and then
that's the deal that we have in place
and then like a few years later we were
like we've been thinking about this deal
and you're ripping us off like this is a
this is a bunch of [ __ ] shady
Chinese people with making our stuff and
lending us the money to buy it for like
China is like America's like you know
there was like there like a kid in high
school who was rich but didn't have any
friends so he would just like buy stuff
for the other kids so they would hang
out with him like you'd be like I got
Knicks tickets if anyone wants to go and
you're like fine I'll do it on the next
game with this guy like that's China
like just make our Walmart some stuff
and give us some money and we'll think
about like Trump will hang out with you
for a few minutes and they're like okay
that sounds pretty good all right that's
my understanding of Finance I'm very
excited for the debate thanks for coming
out everybody enjoy it have a good one
now for the main event you remember oh
yeah
remember the resolution governments of
the advanced industrial economies should
phase out the use of paper money in the
form of large denomination notes and
sharply restrict the use of crypto
currencies here to defend the
affirmative Harvard professor of
economics Kenneth Rogoff
can please come to the stage
[Applause]
taking the negative on the resolution
George Mason University professor of
economics Lawrence white Larry please
come to the stage Jane please close the
voting I asked I met Ken Rogoff a number
of years ago coincidentally at a wedding
and we talked talked about Bobby Fischer
the chess champ I'd actually played a
lot of games with Bobby Fischer because
we knew each other as a kid can it not
but one of his games was annotated by
Bobby Fischer Ken's
great talent literally true was that he
could play at least 10 people
blindfolded and chess was a twenty ten
twenty people polite folks it's just you
tell him the move but he's blindfolded
and and Larry you could play can he be
blindfolded in chess but I think you
chose instead of rats so what ken is
very well practiced in the arts of chess
no doubt extremely well practiced in the
arts of debate ken please come to the
podium and defend the resolution thank
you very much gene and by the way I
kudos to David Smith that's quite an act
to follow as a warm-up act
thanks for the Soho forum and all of you
and to Lawrence white for professor
white for participating in this so I
know I have a tough job ahead of me
because first of all I'm told I actually
didn't know this when I accepted I just
found it out when I got here that this
is a libertarian crowd I'm I'm like to
come out and it's a cash bar and I see
the cash flying I should be grateful
that it's relatively cold weather and I
can't see your Bitcoin in aetherium
tattoos but anyway my my basic
proposition which comes from my 2016
book but actually traces back to work I
did decades earlier was that government
should
more active given more active thought to
how to recalibrate cache and in some I
recommend indefinitely preserving its
use in small transactions but making it
difficult to use for very large
transactions so yes something for $1000
no 40 million dollar apartment and Trump
Tower real estate and I basically view
this as a balance between your right to
privacy which is a right individuals
right to privacy and society's right to
regulate collect taxes etc now the the
issues are actually very related to
Sudha nonnamous crypto currencies and my
book gives that quite a bit of attention
I'll give it less tonight my books about
the past present and future of cache
importantly it's not just about the US
it's really about the entire advanced
world so let me just give you a few
basic facts this is a very educated
crowd and you probably use hundreds a
lot I don't need to tell you but there's
a big disconnect between what's going on
with the supply of cash and the use of
cash all over the advanced economies so
the figure for the United States even if
we think of half of all hundred-dollar
bills are held abroad and that seems
like a high side estimate according to
the Federal Reserve but even if half of
all hundred-dollar bills are held abroad
there's twenty or so for every man woman
and child and the Federal Reserve which
makes a lot of money printing cash we'll
come back to that
it hasn't it made may perhaps 80 billion
dollars last year printing cash by one
accounting it does invest a little bit
in researching its clientele I think by
my calculation at something like two
thousandth of a percent of its profits
are investigating going to investigating
how the cash is used I don't know many
businesses that sort of work like that I
think the reason is they don't want to
know
and I think that's true of many other
central banks but what the Federal
Reserve and the Bundesbank and
governments all over the world find that
looking at this doing surveys lots of
different sources of data from looking
at cash registers many creative things
the use of cash is falling very very
rapidly so of course they're places like
Sweden and the Scandinavian countries
where it's less than 2% of the value of
transactions it's disappearing but even
in the United States it was perhaps a
third the value of transactions twenty
years ago six or seven years ago it
might have been 14% now it's probably
something like six or seven percent and
we're on track to be Sweden in five to
ten years the printing of cash is
exploding I've just given you some
numbers and you can look at the figures
in the book and the question is where is
that that's what I first wrote about
twenty years ago looking at the whole
world the Fed at the time said don't
look at us it's foreigners using it it's
Russian mafia
Argentines you know - it's not we don't
care they like it but that's disconnects
with the fact that they're very similar
figures in the rest of the world that in
almost every advanced country large
notes dominate the currency supply there
ninety percent of the Japanese currency
supply over 90 percent of the Swiss nine
over 90 percent of the euro currency
supply and the US the hundreds alone or
80 percent of the currency supply and
yet no one admits to having them and the
Federal Reserve surveys they're almost
not used in business-to-business legal
tax compliant transactions but you know
roughly five percent of consumers they
serve a report having used one $100 bill
or carried a one $100 bill at some point
during the year but of course that
doesn't get you to the 80 you need for
the four person
and I make the case and I did it I think
using statistics and using different
methods and there have been a lot of I
would say Studies on this that a lot of
it is used in the underground economy
and for illegal transactions now let me
make a few points first I don't I don't
have a moral thing about this it's a
public policy question is it smart
opioids serve a purpose and we should
have them used in some applications but
should the government have made them
basically free for everyone and flooded
the market no it's a question of
calibration I've already made the point
this isn't just about the US I want to
reiterate the point that I'm not for
going cashless I have a very long vision
of this so once everybody studied it and
puts my plan of some sort into effect
honestly my plan I argue for taking
something like five to seven years to
phase out the 50s and hundreds then
maybe after another ten years you can
see how it went and look at the 20s I
did not say to get rid of them overnight
which they did in India some of the
Prime Minister's advisers cited my work
I quickly jumped into the Financial
Times and other places to say wait wait
first of all my book says don't try this
at home if you're an emerging market and
and and warns about trying to do it too
quickly and lastly it actually isn't
also just about getting rid of the
existing notes but there's a constant
push to have larger notes there I'm
getting letters from central bankers and
other people around the world saying you
know we want to have you know let's just
say instead of a you know to hunt the
equivalent of a $200 note we're one of a
$500 note is it a good idea what do I
say and I think the arguments are very
parallel I don't have time here but to
say I've worked on this first 20 years
ago where I disagreed with the Federal
Reserve view that it was all held abroad
and I did
by showing what a universal problem it
is I want to be clear that if they are
being used in tax evasion and crime it's
mostly tax evasion you're not gonna get
rid of it by even if you got rid of all
cash it's not obviously cannot get rid
of it with that we only had standardized
coinage starting in Lydia and western
Turkey in the 7th century BC I guarantee
you they had tax evasion and crime and
Babylon well before that you're not
getting rid of them but if you look at
the numbers I don't really have time to
do that here I think it's pretty
compelling back-of-the-envelope
calculations suggest that it's penny
wise and pound foolish to think that
it's just a wonderful business printing
these hundred dollars even if you cut
crime by a few percent and tax evasion
by say five percent which I think are
very plausible looking at IRS and all
their studies it's it's a pretty big win
financially so a lot of the arguments
against my point of view and I think I
take them all up in the book you know
relate to a few issues so one has to do
with privacy
another is robustness to electric
outages you had hurricane sandy here
there's a financial inclusion what do
you do for people who don't have bank
accounts and then there's central banks
and in some places Treasuries that love
the money and they just don't want to
hear about it
so the central banks this is just
ridiculous I mean if you look at the 80
billion the Fed made from this there are
different ways to calculate it but
that's I think pretty close estimate by
no matter how you calculate it all of
their expenses are a few billion dollars
and frankly even now 20s and below count
for 16 percent of the currency supply
there obviously be a lot of substitution
into that if you got rid of large notes
they'd have plenty of money and as we go
more digital they're gonna have even
more money there are lots of ways that
as the doing the font being the final
clearance they're going
make money not worth talking about
financial inclusions very easily
addressed they've done that already in a
lot of countries by basically providing
free debit a car account free debit
accounts to anyone who's receiving
transfers from the government which
covers almost everyone who doesn't have
some kind of bank account they in the US
the estimates would this be about three
hundred cost about three hundred dollars
per person per year I have to say India
did it for five dollars per person and I
think somewhere in between I don't know
what the Danish I don't know what they
paid in Denmark and Sweden but it's not
terribly expensive to do power to power
outages are certainly a trickier problem
I don't think that's easy but I would do
have a couple things to say about it
first of all if you look at who is
holding cash and the state of our
vulnerability to power outages the cash
is not going to save you and the people
who have cash are not necessarily the
nicest people that except for this crowd
that that that you would want to save
you
ATMs aren't going to work if there's an
EMP blast it's it's not going to be easy
just to have cash I think that ideas for
creating cell phone backup and others
are better but different societies have
handled this India managed to it with
its rather extreme policy of getting rid
of its two largest no its overnight
managed to function as they rejiggered
the economy we actually had a period
when Franklin Roosevelt closed the banks
during the Great Depression where nobody
had cash in New York City and people use
checks and other things and managed so I
think this is a serious issue it takes
some planning but it's just not a reason
to have cash certainly privacy is a very
legitimate issue okay and if you think
this is just about cash and not about
Facebook and Google and the fact the
government has a camera that they're
following and super computers with face
recognition technology which possibly
even know that some of you are here this
isn't just about cash but I would say
it's a balance and so as I discuss you
can if even if we only had $10 bills you
can carry around $100,000 worth of $10
bills in a briefcase it weighs 20 pounds
there's there's there's really a lot you
can do without having very large notes
let me let me conclude with talking
about cyber currencies which raise many
of the similar issues and I've spoken to
many evangelists of cyber currency but
let me just say this technology great
Security's great substituting for the
financial sector great lots of exciting
things happening what the government
can't tolerate is basically having large
denomination notes on steroids it can't
allow people to make large transactions
easily across borders across wherever
without ever having any trace and it's
the usual arguments about money
laundering and such now I understand
that these technologies can be made so
that they're not anonymous but I bet you
the value would fall very very
dramatically most of them and and and so
at the end of the day the government
either has to it can't allow this but if
they the currencies most of them make
themselves not anonymous then certainly
the the coin form they won't be worth
much and let me just conclude by saying
I set my book up looking at the past
present and future of Perun see and I
observe how over history most of the
time it is the private sector that
innovates just like in digital
currencies but at the same time the
private sector may innovate but the
government eventually regulates and
appropriate and certainly that's what's
going on here I do think for the same
arguments that I would have for reducing
and scaling back on the you
of cash I would say the government
should regulate currencies now there are
a lot of international issues I don't
have time to talk about but maybe they
can come up in questions thank you okay
thanks to the Soho forum I'm happy to be
here
I was prepared to criticize the
macroeconomic case for abolishing cash
that didn't really come up so I guess
I'll skip that so most of what you heard
was the argument that to fight crime and
to fight tax evasion we should shift all
but trivial sized transactions to credit
cards and to bank account media media
that leave an electronic data trail for
law enforcement and for tax authorities
I consider this policy proposal part of
a sort of broader movement which has
been called the war on cash when one of
Professor rogoff's reviewers referred to
it as a war on cash he objected and
interestingly not to the term war but to
the term cash because his book doesn't
call for the abolition of all cash just
a large denomination notes but then it
shouldn't have been called the curse of
cash should have in card the curse of
large denomination notes but the
argument of the the crime related
argument in a nutshell is that the
hundred dollar bill is used
disproportionately by criminals in order
to evade their capture so it's a good
idea to get rid of it likewise the 50
dollar bill and when we're ready the
twenty dollar bill and large value
Bitcoin transfers to so cash is a curse
because bad people find it convenient
and implicitly not many good people do
so if we're doing a cost-benefit
analysis and only bad people use it well
we don't really care about their welfare
my argument in a nutshell on the crime
and privacy issue is that large
denomination notes
have greater benefits than they have
drawbacks it's true that criminals like
cash that's not a reason to ban it
unless we also want to ban fast cars
fast boats something that criminals use
more than other people are pleading the
fifth amendment pleading the Fourth
Amendment against unreasonable search
and seizure I don't think we want to do
away with those because they're favored
by criminals so I think eliminating
high-denomination notes and restricting
the use of crypto currencies would be a
costly nuisance for perfectly
law-abiding people but there's a second
category I want to talk about which are
people whose illicit transactions are
actually beneficial black market
transactions underground economy
transactions that don't involve theft or
fraud or force it's a costly nuisance
for them too and it makes our lives less
free and less private so I although
professor Rogoff just mentioned the
privacy issue he didn't say a lot about
it and I think people who want to
prohibit large denomination currency
generally put too little weight on it
the entrepreneur Peter Thiel wants
remarked that crypto is libertarian and
I just want to expand that a little and
say crypto currency and cash are
libertarian meaning promote Liberty
favor Liberty whereas restricting them
is anti Liberty anti libertarian
illiberal in a broader sense and not to
exaggerate too much it's a step in the
direction of it doesn't itself bring
about but it's a step in the direction
of what you might call a financial
panopticon's right the panoptic on was
Bentham's design for a prison where the
prison guards could observe everything
the prisoners are doing in every corner
of the prison I'm not saying we live in
a prison but if you want to give the
federal government more power over the
payment system and you trust them not to
abuse that power let Rheem you let me
remind you about operation choke point
operation choke point was a program
which was kept quiet for a long time by
the Department of Justice and the FDIC
who by just admit
straight of fiat without any
congressional authorization cut off
banking services for legal businesses
but legal businesses they didn't like
they deemed undesirable in particular
payday lenders state licensed marijuana
dealers gun and ammunition dealers
pornographers the FDIC only had to
whisper to banks that customers that
were running these kinds of businesses
were high-risk customers and the banks
would shut their accounts because they
didn't want to anger the FDIC which can
order audits of them and make life
difficult for them only recently have
some of the paper trail come out on this
policy it's still true today that state
licensed legal in that sense marijuana
businesses can't get bank accounts the
Federal Reserve won't let them there was
a group of pot dealers in Denver who
went to the extraordinary lengths of
getting a bank Charter actually a credit
union Charter and then applying to the
Federal Reserve Bank in their district
which is Kansas City saying please
create a master account for us so we can
clear checks like every other credit
union and the Kansas City Fed sat on it
and sat on it and then denied it without
an explanation
so without hundred-dollar bills without
$50 bills certainly without $20 bills
there would be almost no way to do
business in those shops except getting
paid in shoes as the would suggested
earlier
so when banking services are shut off
for people who are doing legal and
harmless business cash is a badge of
freedom the what I call the war on cash
is more accurately described as a war on
people it's people who use cash it's not
that there are attacks on the bills
themselves they don't suffer it's the
people who want to use cash who suffer
they have their Liberty reduced they
have their welfare reduced and banning
large notes is just one part of the
program in the u.s. we still have $100
bill but we used to have a $500 bill we
no longer do Europe has a 500 euro note
but they've already announced it
they're phasing it out so the movement
to reduce large denomination notes has
already had some victories other
measures in in the same direction are
banks being required to file suspicious
activity reports on people who deposit
cash or withdraw cash in suspiciously
large amounts you and I having to
declare at the border how much cash were
carrying if it's over ten thousand
dollars so that those are all in place
now some other countries have more
stringent policies in many countries
there's a maximum on the size of the
allowable cash payment in France and
Spain it's only a thousand euros so you
can't buy a used car with cash in some
countries there's a tax on cash
withdrawals above a certain amount
that's the policy in Nigeria for example
and I note that professor rogoff's book
mentions both of these as possible
options to encourage people to stop
using large denomination cash and one
more item in Greece there is a
requirement that you report the size of
your cash hoard to the government if
it's above 15,000 euros so that's these
are all matters of more surveillance
which is what concerns me I think we
need to worry about the privacy of those
of us who use hundred dollar bills and
Bitcoin it's not right to assume that
we're all criminals and therefore need
to have these things taken away from us
it is true that the use of cash of large
nomination notes in everyday
transactions is pretty small and it's
certainly true that when they take a
survey when a surveyor goes to a
household and says how many
hundred-dollar bills do you have stored
under the floorboards they get a very
small number back so they're and even
after we take out the cash that's
estimated to be abroad there are many
unaccounted for hundred-dollar bills in
circulation but ordinary citizens who
hold hundred-dollar bills as a reserve
against emergencies say in Puerto Rico
against the power grid going down or
because they value privacy those people
are unlikely to divulge to survey takers
what the size of their cash hoards are
so we actually don't know exactly how
many of the hundred-dollar bills are in
criminal hands but we do know that not
all hundred-dollar bill uses it elicits
most of us find $100 bills convenient
now and it again for legal and
non-controversial purposes I've
mentioned buying a used car
I brought a visual aid here this is a
hundred dollar bill so take a look at it
now in case you don't get to see it
later why am i carrying it because I'm
on vacation in New York and it's a
compact way to carry cash in New York
it's an expensive city a European
Central Bank study found that Europeans
use cash to make 32 percent of payments
over a hundred euros it's not clear that
they use hundred euro notes in all those
transactions but plausible that they use
it in most of them and in some countries
in the euro zone the number is even
bigger so it's not just people in
illicit uses but here's the point I want
to make that I think is really
underappreciated not all illicit
currency users are bad people or doing
something that harms the rest of us so
in professor rogoff's book he
distinguishes evaders of taxes on legal
activities versus what he calls outright
criminals but I think we need to divide
outright criminals into two very
different sets of people the violent
criminals the kidnappers the
extortionist the thieves and fences the
terrorists and the distinction is that
those people are playing negative-sum
games they're making us all worse off
and so we should all be for prosecuting
those kinds of activities but then there
are those people who trade in merely
illicit goods and services drug dealers
sex workers poker players undocumented
workers the employers of undocumented
workers and the foreign users we've
talked about those people are engaged in
positive-sum Act
there are mutually beneficial trades
everything economists say about neutral
gains from trade applies to these
transactions and I should mention the
role that Bitcoin plays in helping
people to escape from predatory
government's that's been an important
use case so Venezuelans escaping
hyperinflation they would hold US
dollars but their governments quite
ruthless about cracking down on dollar
use when the government of Cyprus was
going to impose a confiscatory tax on
deposits people use Bitcoin to get their
wealth out of the money bitcoin is very
popular in China because the government
tracks everything but has a harder time
tracking Bitcoin use and generally $100
bills are useful in countries that are
experiencing high inflation and it would
do great damage to the ordinary people
in those countries to take the
hundred-dollar bills away so most of the
unaccounted hundred-dollar bills are
surely in the underground economy where
they're performing useful trading
services very little relatively is in
extortion terrorism and so on so
quashing $100 bills in $50 bills and
later have $20 bills is quashing
voluntary markets and gains from trade
it's treating people who use cash for
these purposes as though their welfare
doesn't count they don't count
disrupting their trade operations by
banning large notes to make it more
difficult for them that's a social cost
that's not a benefit it reduces their
economic welfare to raise the cost of
engaging in these peaceful mutually
beneficial activities there's no gain to
the rest of us so it's got to be a - and
not a plus so the benefits of cash and
Bitcoin users retain privacy of course
there's a technical discussion of how
you retain your privacy using Bitcoin
when all transactions are being recorded
on the blockchain disclaimer I recently
became adviser to what's called a
privacy coin called beam where they're
convinced that Bitcoin isn't private
enough and they want to provide
something that's more pride
we're less information appears in the
blockchain but they don't want to give
an open door to criminals of the violent
kind so part of their design is
transactions will be auditable if the
party to the transaction agrees to it so
if there's a court order saying we need
to look at your transactions the user
will be able to do that currently if you
don't use cash or Bitcoin if you use
transfer of bank accounts nothing is
really private it's all tracked by the
bank and the bank will cooperate when
federal authorities ask them for
individual transaction records so if we
had a world of no cash and no crypto
we'd be in a complete financial
panopticon's the US courts have said
that the Fourth Amendment protection
against unreasonable search and seizure
doesn't apply to the information that
your bank has on your account because it
can't be so important to your privacy if
you revealed it to the bank that's their
logic and so the federal government's
attitude has always been what do you
need privacy for are you up to something
so that's what we have to worry about
and so to wrap up I think we should give
customers the kind of payment media they
want the kind of currency kind of
cryptocurrency in my ideal world all
denomination of currency would be issued
privately so withdraw all the Federal
Reserve notes but let private commercial
banks issue currency denominated in
dollars redeemable in dollars just as
they do today in although it's in pounds
in Scotland Northern Ireland and as they
do in Hong Kong dollars in Hong Kong so
it's not a pie-in-the-sky thing to
reprieve a-- ties currency failing that
bring back the five hundred dollar bill
it was eliminated in 1969 five hundred
dollars today only buys what $100 bill
bought in 1969 so to keep up with
inflation bring back the five hundred
dollar bill failing that at least don't
shrink the public's currency set or
their crypto options let people have
their liberty their dignity in their
preferred payment media
and five ministers vital for Ken well
thank you very much for the spirited
comments so I want to separate the
substance from the hyperbole it's
there's there's a little bit of the
debate on cash like the guns debate if
you're banning semi-automatic weapons
where you could come into this room and
kill everyone quickly you're about to
take away hunting rifles and I think if
we think about taking away large
denomination notes it is not the case
that you wouldn't have been able to buy
your drinks at the bar you wouldn't be
able to buy something for $1,000 with
$20 bills or frankly $10 bills and by
the way if it got burdensome to count
the ten dollar bills cash counting
machines cost almost nothing
I think the good bad this is just absurd
hyperbole I make very clear in my book
that the vast majority of holdings in
the US are by people in what we call the
shadow economy which are doing legal
things but not paying taxes we can come
to the regulations and this isn't a
matter of I want the government to be
infinitely big or I want them to be able
to collect a lot of taxes about what we
economists nerdily call horizontal
equity if two people earn the same thing
they should get the same return there's
no reason that just because a business
is cash intensive that it should pay a
lower tax rate that we should have more
investment into that yes absolutely to
adults
who you know consenting adults should be
able to engage in a transaction but it
shouldn't necessarily be taxed hurt by
using cash I won't even get into the
part about the end about the currencies
which just like I don't even know where
it's not I I think getting into private
currencies with that's a long topic but
I will take up the foreign policy
question that they're all these great
uses these nice people in Moscow use it
to buy apartments and these nice all
ARC's and china you know get their money
out and sure i'll go for all of that but
there are a lot of bad uses of currency
abroad used in a lot of insurgent
movements well maybe some of them are
good but use a lot of a certain
movements it's used very heavily in
human trafficking there is the drug
trade many many things a lot of not nice
people abroad do have cash and I don't
know what the balance is but to make the
case for keeping large denomination
notes is our foreign policy I find a
little bit absurd as far as the crypto
currencies I mean please the the
currencies on scale put the crypto
currencies it's unlimited the size of it
the government simply has to have some
handle I got a couple of oats the
government has to have some kind of
handle on this the government when it
issues digital currencies and by the way
whether you like cash or not you can
kiss it goodbye it's going that's how
the world is playing out it's going so
down in legal transactions I use
hundred-dollar bills sometimes I have no
moral objections but in many places
especially in Boston they look at it and
they look at me and they probably
figured there's about maybe a 20% chance
I got this legitimately but in another
you know in another 10 years it's going
to be 2% and eventually it's gonna come
out but I you know we we just can't
allow this on on this on that scale with
crypto currencies that's that's that's
that's not going to happen one last
point and this is very nerdy but cash by
the way won't be anonymous soon enough
there now cash register machines that
I'm afraid will surely get required that
read the serial numbers as you feed the
men they're taking your picture at the
same time and so governments are going
to end up having to call it in anyway
but I would like to do it sooner
[Applause]
we waited for Mary so I was a little
puzzled when you said that I could carry
$100,000 in a suitcase because what's
the point then within $10 bills
hmm briefcase sorry briefcase even
smaller so that makes me wonder if there
are very few transactions that this is
going to make impossible or even raise
the cost of very much I wonder what the
point is in the macro part of your
argument which we didn't get into the
principal was that if we make cash
bulkier we'll make it harder to store
and that will mean that people store
less of it and then we can have a
monetary policy which has negative
interest rates without people being able
to flee into cash but if $100,000 in $10
bills isn't that bulky doesn't seem that
it would have much effect on diminishing
the size of the underground economy
anyway at one point you said that
government can't tolerate certain kinds
of uses of money clearly government's
don't want to tolerate tax evasion
that's certainly understandable but I
think there's a some word to be said on
behalf of tax evaders that governments
like to raise taxes until they meet
popular resistance and some of us resist
by writing op-eds but other people
resist by evading taxes and by doing
that they make it more difficult for
governments to grow and so if you think
that government is already too large
then you have to have a little bit of
sympathy with tax evaders the point
about horizontal equity I'm not quite
sure what to say about I don't I'm not
saying that people should be subject to
different tax
rulz if they use cash so I'm not I'm not
saying the reason to allow people to use
cash is in to enable tax evasion we can
discuss what the optimal level of taxes
is anyway but to the extent that having
cash in circulation holds down the
effective tax rate and therefore the
average tax rate maybe I should say
holds down the amount of revenue the
federal government gets then that's a
point in its favor may or may not be
decisive that depends on your values I
guess when you said we're gonna have to
kiss cash goodbye I'm okay with anybody
who wants to live a cashless life I'm in
favor of stores being able to say we
don't accept hundred-dollar bills I'm
even in favor of restaurants being
allowed to say and this is an issue in
New York City we don't accept cash we
only accept cards if they want to pursue
that policy that's great but that kind
of policy is only going to survive if
it's popular with their customers what
I'm against is the compulsion that
restricts people's options to use cash
when it's the most convenient payment
mechanism for them and so I don't want
to be hyperbolic I recognize that you
say it's too soon for less developed
countries that you've sort of washed
your hands of the mo d D monetization
policy that's to your credit but I think
we have to worry about the size of
government in the US we have to think
about the privacy of ordinary citizens
and we have to be sympathetic to
transactions in the underground economy
there's really no good purpose served in
my view by shutting them down by making
cash bulkier and by trying to restrict
them that way if it would in fact have
that effect so it seems to me that if if
the government wants to get your your
bank transaction records they should
need more than just
subpoena they should need a court order
or a search warrant or something like
that and until then if cash provides a
mechanism for making payments without
being subject to that kind of scrutiny
that's okay with me thank you
[Applause]
thanks very much to both of you we now
start moving to the QA portion of the
evening just for starters
ken and Larry to pick up the the
handheld mics just to make sure and
don't hold them hold them just a few a
little bit of side of your mouth so that
you know you don't listen to them and
the first invitation to either view and
an invitation indeed for the rest of 30
minutes is that if either of you wants
to put a question to the other please do
so if you'd like to do it now or later
any questions to either side can - Larry
Larry - Ken no yes I don't have anything
pressing that I can't come back - okay
Oh Larry anything - Ken yes okay I
before I take it to the audience I just
want to take a moderators prerogative
and put a question to Ken which you can
come in and allow me as you know ken
Larry is making a distinction between
laws governing transactions that a lot
of people think are bad laws and unjust
laws laws making it illegal for people
to buy heroin or people to buy sex
workers people to gamble all of those
activities that do take up a lot of cash
do you but do you feel that if you if
you if somebody did objects those laws
and like those transactions would you
have a different view of the use of cash
how does that affect your view yeah so
I'm a look at this at a marginal point
of view I don't make the argument that
when you get rid of fifteen hundred
dollar bills crimes going down by fifty
percent
I make arguments like you know it would
probably go down at least five percent
yeah
what's happening when it's just going
down five
well people who have really high-value
transactions or where it's really
important to them bear the larger
friction
they either lug the you know briefcase
full of the $10 bills to make $100,000
transaction they use gold coins uncut
diamonds Bitcoin shoes as the comedian
before a set so you're you're exactly
putting higher tax on that kind of
transaction and a lot of them won't
change and so you're not shutting the
door it's not an absolute I meant but
but I meant it may just insist on
whether I meant that categorically there
was a viewpoint that the sale of drugs
to is a capital set between consenting
adults the sale of sex were gambling
that these are not crimes at all in an
ethical sense and sure yeah so I'm okay
that's splitting hairs I I don't you
know I I do think human trafficking is
quite trafficking that's the example
that's the example I use and well for
sex but I don't I don't say look job now
but I I think actually there are things
like marijuana where societal norms
evolved and if you hadn't had ways of
doing the transactions it wouldn't
happen I talk about that at length in
the book but it's at the margin and you
know the question of what you gain not
necessarily this would rescue the world
but they are big numbers
if you cut crime by a few percent it's
that's actually probably as much as a
lot of the expenditures on law
enforcement do in many cities
if you cut tax evasion by five percent
this is a big deal compared to the
printing of cash so it's not you know
I'm not talking in terms of sweeping
everything away coming from Larry and
you wanted to go to the question coming
Chloe no well I think I think it does
affect the way one weights the use of K
but or weights the cost-benefit analysis
if you make the distinction between
peaceful illicit transactions and you
know violent criminal
actions and realize that the use of cash
is concentrated in the first and not in
the second yes okay thanks
audience questions again please flesh
your question is a question and if you
want say to whom the which person the
question is addressed go ahead
my question is for professor Rogoff I
haven't had the opportunity to read your
book but I understand your focus on
public policy to put another way some of
the statements we've already heard there
are other public policy options for
solving the issues that you're talking
about we could legalize much of many
drugs we could make no prostitution
legal we could there are other public
policy options regarding tax evasion we
could lower tax rates sufficiently that
it wouldn't be worth it to evade taxes
by using large denomination notes so why
do you pose the pardon the expression
the statist solution to the problems you
have identified rather than the
non-status solutions well I mean first
of all just to be clear and my book fix
and papers make very clear by far the
large bulk of this is tax evasion not
prostitution and such but by the way
from what I've seen a lot of that's done
with credit cards anyway already by the
way you know as far as for lowering tax
rates the size of the government I
realized these things get this group
really worked up first of all you could
lower tax rates if you did nothing else
and you who reduce tax evasion but you
didn't raise government spending you are
lowering tax rates that I'd like to
observe now would this somehow make the
size of government much bigger you know
I I guess it's fair to say at the margin
it could I don't necessarily think
that's like a first order a fact out of
this but I think it's it the first order
of fact is to make taxation fairer
Thanks
hey coming Larry no no okay all right
next question
my question is for both do you think
that money production by the state is
beneficial I said Larry you're 12
compared to what it's a private
production of money no I think private
production of money has a pretty good
track record that creating central banks
was not a good idea that leaving the
gold standard was not a good idea and
the two things kind of went hand-in-hand
it all fell apart in the first world war
[Music]
we have government's printing money now
because we have unpacked money fiat
money
somebody's got to produce it somebody's
got to control the quantity so we have
central banks so from that point of view
compared to a world without any currency
they do something useful but so does the
post office do something useful carrying
first-class mail but it's wrong to give
them a monopoly and it could be done
entirely privately and used to be done
entirely privately with like I say a
pretty good track record I mean I've
study that in pretty great detail but
it's you know it's politically pretty
far out at this point to imagine that
being the next thing on the Congress's
agenda okay no I'm professor why it's
done important work in this area but I
will say I don't share the view at all
that it was a mistake going off the gold
standard I think it's no coincidence
table when we had World War 1 that was
really the end of it and once it had
lost its credibility was never coming
back and the modern Central Bank works
pretty darn well and if you you know
read the white paper that founded
Bitcoin making it sound like you know
central banks are gonna create inflation
everything's going to be a disaster I
think the advent of independent central
bank says work more technocratic central
bank's has worked very very well next
question
yeah my question is for professor Rogoff
you seem to be acting under the
assumption that governments can control
Bitcoin and stop down Bitcoin I'm
wondering what's the source of that
assumption
you know it's Bitcoin evolves it's
getting more private much harder for
governments to control and have you
considered that if you do away with some
high denomination bills all you're gonna
do is criminals will actually or tax
evaders will just you're just gonna
hasten the the transition to crypto
currencies as an alternative well i
invite you to read my book which
considers this a lot but as far as what
governments can do i i sometimes you
know when i spoke and given a seminar
have somebody who has a lot of bitcoin
come up and say you can't stop but
there's nothing the government can do
and i'm afraid that's not the case i'm
governments can make it illegal at an
extreme for banks to accept it they
could make it illegal for retail stores
to take it and by the way this this is
this will happen and then the person
comes back and says wait but the store
just takes it and i give them the good
and we just make the transaction you
never know about it so what if it's
illegal and of course this is a lot if
anyone knows anything about money
laundering and how this works the store
had to buy the good that they were
selling from somebody so that would have
to be done in bitcoin we find many long
chains and cash like this if you use UPS
they would have to be paid in bitcoin
it's really not very easy to do
anonymously and I'm actually very
careful when I a pine on Bitcoin never
to say that it's gonna be worth nothing
which many people do because I simply
think it's value will be circumscribed
by the fact that you're not going to be
able to it's not going to be very liquid
in the legal economy and that's going to
dramatically limit its value but yes
governments will certainly do this and
yes it will have a big effect comment
yeah I think that's basically right
governments can drive Bitcoin
underground they can't stop peer-to-peer
transaction
but peer-to-peer transactions are quite
awkward for most people most people who
use Bitcoin keep their money at
exchanges to make it more like using a
bank account and until better at least
until better interfaces come along that
make it like using PayPal or something
on your phone that's an obstacle to
Bitcoin being convenient for people to
use even when it's illegal next question
for progressive Rogoff would you endorse
as a compromise say a policy in which we
got rid of a lot of large denomination
bills but in exchange banks got a lot
more legal protection to basically
ensure a lot more privacy for their
customers in the United States well
that's a that's a tough question I would
certainly favor when central banks start
issuing digital currencies and
Licensing's but banks issued digital
currencies finding ways to have small
scale amounts that would have such a
substantial amount of privacy it's very
hard to have absolute privacy from the
government if they really want you in
this and even in the case of lawsuits to
have privacy from businesses and
individuals but I think those
protections could be hardened Christine
Lagarde who's the head of the IMF gave a
speech on central bank digital
currencies recently and she made the
claim that governments can provide more
privacy than in payments than the
private sector provides which I guess
somebody told her that it's always a
good idea to have a laugh line in your
speech but but the idea that governments
will allow central banks to provide more
privacy than they allow commercial banks
to provide to their customers is just
laughable next question
hi professor Rogoff I really do
appreciate the fact that you took the
time to try to address the concerns
about impingements upon freedoms as much
as I might have been unpersuaded but
what I didn't hear you address and what
I'd like to hear you comment on whether
you're concerned by would be the
necessary impingement upon individual
freedoms caused by the supranational
entities that would have to administer a
cashless and Bitcoin las' system namely
today Visa and MasterCard so in your
system you again might not be these and
MasterCard in the future but it would
likely be a similar monopoly or duopoly
you'd have a completely unaccountable
entity not bound by the US Constitution
not bound by any voters just bound by a
couple guys in a room frankly that can
determine who is able or not able to
receive payments and I see you laughing
but we see this today
I mean Visa MasterCard regularly I'm
almost finished
Visa MasterCard regularly shut off the
ability for merchants to collect
payments for no other reason that they
find their business objectionable or
sometimes just because they find the
owner of the business objectionable as
we saw with WikiLeaks right that's was a
huge impingement on freedom of speech
when that happened and that's a
real-life example so I'd like to hear
just your thoughts comments if that
concerns you first of all I just want to
be clear I have nothing to do with Visa
or MasterCard in my remarks that follow
but surely if we had the heads of Visa
and MasterCard here and they were
telling you their sob stories they're
regulated to Wazzu I think the problem
with Visa and MasterCard is that the
government particularly in the United
States has allowed them to have the
rails of the system where you can clear
transactions they're really only a
couple ways to do it
that's where the monopoly is that could
easily be broken there shouldn't be the
kind of a monopoly it just the way that
tell a cellphone costs have dramatically
fallen now that competition policy is
finally working that could be done it's
happened in Europe it's happened
in India it hasn't happened in the
United States as far as far as not being
answerable that means that's just not
true they're there they are regulated
very heavily in every country they
operate but they should be subject to
much more competition I agree with that
these in mastercard of course are owned
by groups of banks and so they're
subject to the regulations that banks
are subject to and they don't want to
anger the regulatory authorities so they
will preemptively shut off accounts of
people who they think might anger the
authorities and that's unfortunate
question yes my name is Eduardo Marti
I'm from Boris iris you mention
Argentines central bank was created in
Argentina in 1945 and the eBridge
inflation per year was 45% so the only
way we have to protect ourself is saving
in dollars and most decades has been
forbidden to buy or sell dollars but
every single agent in ian has bird ink
in his garden some dollars so the
quantity the amount of money we say was
between 300 or 400 billion dollars if
you just if we don't have access we buy
and sell properties the real estate just
with backs of dollars if you don't allow
us to use those dollars what are we
going to do with them we are going to
come back here to buy and you'll be
prepared for a high inflation because
this is not just the case of Argentina I
better another 50 countries the citizens
trying to escape from government and
dictatorship we save in dollar so we are
all all of us we are coming here and
just to buy things well I mean the the
numbers you gave her not what the
Federal Reserve has they have pretty
good data on shipments and how much
money is abroad and
not urgent and it does not have three or
four hundred billion of our currency it
must be maybe a hundred billion or
something maybe we have the the total
currency supplies one point four
trillion the Fed estimates 40% of its
abroad Argentina is one of the big big
users there's Argentina China and Russia
are sort of the big three but as I say
look at go to Colombia go to Mexico and
ask if the hundred-dollar bills doing
good things in those places and I
guarantee you it's not then again there
are a lot of you know places facing
revolutionary movements the idea that we
should provide the hundred-dollar bill
as our foreign policy if we want to make
it explicitly fine but that should be
looked at much more carefully I I think
it's a very mixed bag coming yeah I
wouldn't put it in terms of foreign
policy but I agree with that duardo that
it would be a sort of humanitarian
disaster if people whose only stable
store of value is the US dollar or only
readily accessible store value as the US
dollar were cut off from that or had to
save in bags and bags of ten dollar
bills
question I need further questions from
the audience yes go ahead
so it was mentioned earlier and I guess
you mentioned it but it never really
came back around I wanted to go
specifically on the kind of
international issue right because
obviously as we have increasingly
interconnected global banks and
financial institutions you have a lot of
cross regulatory across jurisdictional
regulatory enforcement and so I guess
kind of two related questions a do you
think there is value in having kind of
less cross jurisdictional regulatory
enforcement in the financial space and B
do you think it's realistic that that
might actually come about as we move
towards a more cash flow society just
you know naturally as people don't like
cash and don't like friction it's a good
question before I take that I just want
to emphasize my books not only about the
United States there are a lot of other
countries most of whom they're kept the
Canadians the Australians there
cash is not used abroad and I'm actually
very clear in the book that the issue is
our most nuance for the United States
but the u.s. as important as the dollar
is is only accounting you know for maybe
a quarter or even less of the global
cash supply as far as cross-border
regulation no I mean I think I think the
problems we live in a very financially
integrated world where we we need to
have some kind of cross-border
regulation and a lot and a lot of issues
I I don't I I certainly don't regard
myself as left-leaning although maybe in
this crowd I am i don't agree it I think
the Thomas Piketty idea of we should
enforce a global tax on capital so you
can't escape and by the way it should
just be for the we should just share it
with the advanced countries the less
developed countries shouldn't get
anything that this is this is a bridge
too far but no absolutely we live in
this very connected world of trade and
finance we're not having cross-border
regulations really not possible
I would like to see more cross-border
competition in banking one of the
promises of the European Union was to
allow an integrated one financial market
and it's been obstructed by the national
regulatory bodies that the national
central banks but the the biggest
problems of bad customer service and
uncompetitive rates of return in banking
are where competition is most restricted
to say I strongly agree with that point
that's been a big problem in Europe okay
we've got some agreement question so we
grant the concern that there's a lot of
bad activity that happens due due to
cash but also grant the concern that
there is you know significant risk to
you know global systems these kind of
Penn opticon type type of fact that
we're starting to see with the with the
spread of Internet technology it seems
like there's a there's another option
for how you could significantly reduce
the risk and that's
pterence we have the FBI which will go
after organized crime here in the US the
crypto community is familiar with this
organization called the Securities
Exchange Commission they've been fairly
active in the space recently to very
good effect in my view personally and
then for over overseas actors there's
the Joint Special Operations Command
which is more than capable of handling
terrorists that are not taken care of
through you know through restrictions
within the banking trade system so why
is pre-empting the ability to transact a
better way to approach this problem then
saying having deterrent effects that
that are much less likely to catch up
the the little guy who we don't
necessarily want to go after in the wide
netic s well a lot of these agencies
that you're citing Lobby very hard for
restricting the use of cash so to the
tax authorities the British have looked
at this very heart by the way in the use
of cash in their country the the idea
exactly is to find a way to calibrate
things so that you're penalizing more
large players and not small players I do
not know if my suggestions the best way
of addressing things but that's the
object you want to prevent you know the
multi-million dollar deals you don't
want to prevent prevent the you know a
couple thousand dollar deals and I don't
know where we want to draw the line in
between we can debate that but I think
it's gone too far in one direction next
gentleman thank you I do think we've
addressed a lot of the issues concerning
privacy and use of cash for criminal
activity but I think in the example of
cryptocurrencies specifically the vast
majority of economic activity concerning
cryptocurrencies is for investment or
speculative purposes so I'd be curious
to get thoughts on what value banning or
severely restricting cryptocurrencies
would bring
if they're going to restrict people's
ability to invest and build out a new
financial ecosystem
yeah I'm concerned about that but you're
right most cryptocurrency transactions
are for other currencies it's not about
buying drugs although there was famously
the Silk Road marketplace it's not about
extortion or anything else although
there have been cases of ransomware
where the ransom was supposed to be paid
in Bitcoin but those are the exceptions
that's a very small one or two percent
of Bitcoin transactions and I guess it's
people are using it as a way to hedge
against the risks of other currencies
and that's something they should be
allowed to do we have tax rules about
paying for capital gains in Bitcoin
which I think are kind of ridiculous
because if you think of it as a currency
they should be taxed the way gains and
foreign currency or taxed rather than in
buying collectibles or gold coins well I
mean to get into crypto currencies and
I'm really glad you asked that question
it is a very broad broad topic first of
all I'm not I I Ritz really the issues
of being able to use them for anonymous
transactions that's the issue
so I'm familiar with some where you can
switch a switch and it's not anonymous
it's like you paid with a credit card
I've got no problems with that
that's just fine the questions where the
core demand is from anonymity I would
submit that a decentralized
permissionless system is simply not
going to be competitive economically
with a permission system with a central
player like a central bank they're just
not going to be competitive if you take
away the anonymity but I'm willing to
write to run that I fear that if there
aren't transactions uses final uses for
crypto currencies or whatever they
actually are there their value will not
turn out to be that much I might say my
view on this is that there's a chance a
small chance crypto currencies might be
worth a lot in some dystopian future and
you're buying a lottery ticket on that
when you've got cryptocurrency it's a
large chance it'll be worth nothing and
a small chance it will be worth a lot
and there's a market for that question
yeah this is for professor Roy Goff
we've seen that there have been several
hearings in the Senate and the house
about crypto currencies and it based on
the the tone of the questions being
asked whether from both sides of the
aisle it doesn't seem like there's the
political interest in putting forth the
measures that you were describing of
essentially making it so that you can't
use crypto currencies at a retail
location and so where do you see the
motivation coming for democratically
elected governments I know that in China
it's easy for them to ban Bitcoin but in
countries where they have to be
responsive to voters to some extent
where's this motivation coming from and
you mentioned assault rifles right like
assault rifles didn't get banned after
Sandy Hook if there was ever an
opportunity to do that it was then
so gee are you waiting for some terrible
event that was financed by Bitcoin to
happen or what's the political game plan
boy if you're gonna refer to what set
its Senate hearings as being the state
of intellectual play with regulators
look at look at when Mark Zuckerberg
went and they were trying to question
him about Facebook they just have no
idea what they're talking about but the
regulator's at central banks who are
ultimately have the technical capacity
to do this and to a lesser extent of
Treasuries they're all over this and I
think exactly if you want to know what's
happening it's that they see a lot of
innovation taking place but they're not
really doing anything with it yet and
they're just sort of sitting back
and if it ever reaches a point where
they're actually being used for
something they'll come in very quickly
but I think a lot of central banks have
been very restrained deliberately
figuring you know let them work this out
then we'll steal it I think that's the
gentleman who made trouble for Janet
Yellen
yes well back on the topic of central
banking the big trouble that could ask a
question oh yeah one thing that I
haven't heard discussed tonight is
negative interest rates and as though
central banks didn't need yet another
tool to extend their vampire alik
vampire like grass predictable from this
guy across the world is a is being able
to charge people simply for having money
and can I have read your book and you
would argue that if we could eliminate
cash it would eliminate one of the final
barriers to have full technocratic
control over all monetary levers so
could I please hear from both of you
your respective arguments for and
perhaps against why we should want to
eliminate the last or one of the last
barriers against negative interest rates
this guy's read your book ken and that's
a distinguished term and Larry why don't
you take take it first go so he said for
and against so I'm against but yeah this
is an important strand in in professor
rogoff's book that we would enable more
leeway to central bank policy to push
interest rates into the negative range
by making taking away the effective
lower bound set by the cost of storing
cash so if you can store cash for a
tenth of a percent per year and I don't
know how many of you have seen Breaking
Bad but I want to add that Walter White
is not a relative of mine he has the
problem of storing all the hundred
dollar bills he's gotten his business if
it was $10 bills he'd need a warehouse
space ten times as big so if the the
cost of storing cash is ten times as
great
and interest rates can be pushed to
negative 1 or if it's 20 times as great
to negative 2 I have a suggestion by the
way instead of making it 10 10 dollar
bills that people store that takes a lot
of ink just make a hundred dollar bill
ten times as thick so print it on
cardboard and that's a proposal has been
made that's a policy you can actually
calibrate and in the limit you can
imagine $100 cubes yeah but it's it's
not exactly pro-consumer to have a tax
on a bank account that the public can't
escape because they can no longer
withdraw if you completely abolished
cash they can't withdraw their money
from the bank or lesser step in that
direction make it very cumbersome to
withdraw money from the bank so I don't
think negative interest rates are
necessary but that's a long argument so
a significant part of my book does deal
with it but the question posed I thought
didn't the the first of all you can have
negative interest rate policy and exempt
99% or 0.9% of people by just having a
couple thousand dollars they're allowed
to hold without negative interest rates
because you're not trying to get it
small people trying to save a few
thousand dollars you're trying to get it
pension funds and insurance companies
storing tens of billions of dollars in
cash that's where the money market is
nobody cares what the little players do
and you're doing negative interest rates
because inflation is becoming negative
and the economy's in a deep recession
and the same policies that let you pay
negative interest rates by the way it
lets you pay positive interest rates in
in normal times and lastly I'd say as my
book explains you actually could have a
hundred thousand dollar bills and
there's still ways to have negative
interest rates by taxing cash redeposits
into the banking system but again this
is something you'd only use in the
extreme and you may not like it but boy
how much do you like the other proposals
that are going to come instead which is
increasing the size of government by 5%
where there's
recession I don't think Professor
White's gonna endorse that making the
inflation rate on average all the time
much higher I can't even get into
helicopter money but my book treats all
these issues and I regard negative
interest rates as much the most elegant
way of dealing with another financial
crisis and much it's much the least evil
compared to other options that you'll
see that will close the this Q&A session
thanks very much to all the questioners
thanks guys if you go first on the
summation you'll you you can take the
podium if you'd like oh okay can I I
appreciate very much your listening to
these arguments it's funny
they're almost no economists who've ever
worked on this when I study
macroeconomics anything having to do
with the plumbing of the system so
boring it's not it you want to have a
complicated mathematical model and a big
statistical apparatus for trying to
think about things and the idea that
something so mundane as currency or cash
that actually have significant effects
is something that people dismiss it's
very recently becoming a little bit more
fashionable thanks to all the
innovations and technology Bitcoin and
whatever but I do think these are issues
that need to be taken seriously the
first thing my book calls for is to form
you know more working groups
Commission's around the world to like
analyze these issues there are some very
basic things that governments could do
again I mentioned the statistic that I
think the Federal Reserve spends a
couple thousandth of a percent of its
eighty billion dollars a year on
studying what its product is used for
can you imagine a company that has a
revenue stream like that
that devotes nothing to studying how
it's used
I refer in the book to what the Federal
Reserve and other central banks do is
reverse money laundering money
laundering takes dirty money and makes
it clean
they take clean money and it ends up
being dirty there's some very simple
things the government could do to get
better information I've in in addition
to getting a lot of death threats from
my book I've also gotten a lot of
letters from law enforcement officials
from Interpol FBI various State sheriffs
and whatever where they say you know
we're constantly I can't tell you how
many times we busted someone for tax
evasion for a crime and we find a wall
you know filled of lot with large
nomination notes we can actually get
that information when you prosecute
somebody and you found cash you not only
have to say how much cash we found you
actually have to list the serial numbers
of each of the bills but there's no
there's no effort to gather this
information to have a clearinghouse for
it
that's the kind of thing that would be
very inexpensive compared to the 80
billion dollars they spend to put data
together to study this and if I'm wrong
and tax evaders aren't using it and you
know criminals aren't using it and you
say study it more closely and it's all
good well that's great I'm glad it was
thought about and I'm that I would
accept that outcome I do think that by
and large that's not what they're
finding I would by the way I forgot to
mention I would dispute the statistic
about the use of cash in Europe it's the
the number of transactions is high but
the value of transactions is actually
plummeting in Europe just as it's
plummeting everywhere else anyway thank
you for listening to me
[Applause]
well I would have thank professor Rogoff
for being good sport and coming to this
venue although as he says he wasn't
quite aware of the slant of the audience
so in a sense I've had a less
challenging task of merely representing
what many of you probably already
believe but the challenge of course is
to beat the point spread in this style
of debate and I want to thank professor
Rogoff in his book for raising the issue
of what kind of money do we want to have
what kind of payment system do we want
to have who do we want to run it which
puts back on the table issues about
financial privacy which have been you
know kind of sleeping for many years and
issues about what kind of payment system
how private it should be what kind of
experimentation should we allow in
payment systems and my view of course is
the more competition the more
experimentation the better I certainly
think we want to have a legal system
that prosecutes violent crime I don't
think most large denomination cash uses
violent crime at some of it not a lot of
it but for a long time it's been the
tradition in anglo-american law and
probably in continental law too
that we take a presumption of innocence
and so we we put the burden of proof on
the prosecution in in criminal cases and
we don't sort of outlaw things because
they're associated with the criminality
of a certain kind we don't outlaw as I
said before fast boats and fast cars
and it seems to be in that spirit if we
want to prosecute tax evasion we do it
by gathering information on people
evading taxes rather than by restricting
the option of people who are law-abiding
and people who are using cash in order
to evade detection of their breaking the
laws against the sale of what they're
selling which is independent of doing it
for tax evasion purposes I mean so
that's what I think we want to be
concerned with and I think the more
payment options people have the better
they are clearly it's not the case that
the more crime we have the better but
there are other ways to fight crime as
one of the questioners have brought up
and that that's how we should pursue it
so that we don't restrict people's
payment options in the cause of making
life less convenient for criminals thank
you
[Applause]
okay thank you both for a brilliant and
extremely civil exchange we're now going
to open up the final voting Jane is
opening it up again the resolution is
governments of the advanced industrial
economies should phase out the use of
paper money in the form of large
denomination notes and sharply restrict
the use of crypto currencies and does
sell okay oh my gosh all right well it
was very close
ken you got twelve point six six percent
of the vote initially but that doesn't
matter Tim it's a question of how well
you out now you picked up you went up to
fifteen point one nine percent therefore
you gained there are people in this
audience with two point five three
percent you gained now there's no look
if they were a cash prize for who wins
then they would be gaming of the system
you know okay now a Larry actually began
predictably with seventy three point
four percent of the new record yes yeah
that is that actually is a new record
normally the maximum anybody be guns
where there's a best sixty percent the
latter vendors say there were thirteen
nearly 14 percent undecided so that and
that's a new low for undecided but
seventy three point five three percent
but Larry you went up so the number to
beat was two point five three percent
Larry you went up by seventy eight to
seventy eight point forty percent
therefore you get the little gable
gained a little more than five
percentage points two point five to five
I have to say is pretty close
although Larry you get the tootsie roll
Congrats
[Music]